meanwhile on the palm springs awards
gala red carpet
the fans serenaded the birthday boy who
turns 40 for tomorrow he was honored
with the festival's Director of the Year
award for a star is born
and of course Mary Hart had another
surprise for him
thank you Make A Wish thank you for your
energy over here come out like ten
minutes in and then you like bring it
all the way which is not easy year after
year you doing this incredible does it
doing this all now make a difference
to you being a daddy Oh everything's
different when you're dead the legendary
and very beautiful very hard it was the
sixteenth year in a row Mary is hosted
and handled the double duty of doing our
exclusive backstage interviews the
hectic pace kept Mary on the move I'm
gonna go back out and go to work on
stage good night everyone
ét Mary Hart Melissa was honored with
the spotlight award for her work in can
you ever forgive me I think that if
you'd asked me at 18 years old how a
spotlight was going to factor into my
future there's a pretty good chance that
I would have guessed like a prison break
gone wrong for me and my parents are
super shocked and your parents are still
surprised oh my god yes I think that
every once while they're like haha it's
just not the way we thought it was gonna
work out other big winners include
Timothy sha'lame the cast of Mary
Poppins returns and Regina King she and
her if Beale Street could talk director
also got to work our Mike if you live in
Palm Springs this is Entertainment
Tonight with an energetic Jim Carrey
presented the Vanguard Award to the
stars and director of Green Book
backstage he stole our flowers squeezed
around Jim suggests my blossoming heart
this film made my heart blossom Jim
Carrey always Jim Carrey and by the way
the chemistry in this movie between Vigo
and Maher Sheila is unbelievable one of
my favorites of the year I think it's
gonna become a classic you just watch it
over and over again right you hit it on
the head
[Music]